so we're here at the cold con - how have
you enjoyed it today or it has been fun
because I everyone's been really nice
but thanks no it's it's lovely to get to
just show the films people after talking
about them for a year and I think it's
been the reaction - it's really great
because people seem to be loved it and
they've also got it and that's been
really pleasing now we heard in the Q&A
and I talked to Tom earlier how that
came about through a conversation you
had with him about how he'd love to his
ideal role would be Lenny from mice and
men so what the kind of did that spark
off in your mind to bring us the film
that we saw today
it was sparked off when he was actually
just kind of evolving from that
character and then trying to forget the
character he wants to play you to try
and figure out what would make his
character turn out that way
so was the evolution of the character
and then kind of also what would kind of
because his character is quite dark he's
also you know he's not a bad person as a
world there's just kind of a lot of
events happen and I kind of kind of
wanted to show how he was grown and not
grown when we actually do that so that's
kind of like just kind of evolved from
these characters in Slough and how about
the tone of the film as well did you say
it's dark I mean what kind of films
influenced you when you were writing the
script and then directing it well it's
dark but I also quite see it as being
quite beautiful because I mean it is
there's a there's a lot of catharsis to
it and you're seeing the kind of the
relationship between the brothers and
between other various people and I
wanted to kind of try and create that
world I love watching Kia Soul ski event
vendors work on a guy who's kind of
Paris taxes and kind of three colors
blue which kind of were what was
interesting needs to be done as well
another one he's Avedon but not another
film though no no no no no the film
comes not at all but just actually from
descriptions in the book in terms of how
Steinbeck writes trying to create that
type of world and how the characters
later each other yeah filmed it in 14
days which is quite something isn't it
to make a feature film in that amount of
time what were the kind of challenges
you had to deal with doing that I mean
the problem with that is that if you
lose if you lose an hour you can end up
losing a scene and so there's sunders
scenes there to cut because
suffered because he couldn't you know
they just didn't quite work it no time
to really workshop whether what kind of
if something wasn't working it was very
little time to it would all a very
pretty story warden had to follow a very
very brisk pattern so that was the
biggest challenge if you do something
like night you saying about
storyboarding and maybe losing some
scenes for the time what kind of do you
have any rehearse or time and stuff like
that before getting going
no I mean it didn't lose any scenes it
just meant for some of the scenes
wouldn't have had the the kind of the
the impact that they wanted because
maybe I couldn't do certain things if I
didn't lose anything didn't drop
anything ever but it just meant they did
enough time with certain scenes that
kind of shoot different angles and kind
of give them certain energy and then no
didn't have any time for us was bossy
you work with actors you trust you can I
go I know you're gonna do this you do a
quick rehearsal a like 20 minutes before
but not you know nothing nothing
substantial now you've written this you
directed a produced it and you're in it
as well that must be pretty difficult
task to do all of those things I mean
some of them happen at different times
but directing and acting is at the same
time isn't it yeah but I it's easy when
you work on people who you trust if you
got a crew you trust to do their job and
do what they're going to do and then you
all kind of work together and then if
you work real acting so you know are
good and I just trust and do other
things I'd have to worry about it so
much
obviously you've got number of you work
before of course Tom plays your brother
in the film with Brian fortune in there
as well and in a small role you've got
Jack morena how did he come on board
because I work to Jack Gary Shaw is
directing exactly zero the new one or
year one he did a thing back to Colin
and I think the Colin and Jack
explaining Freddy and they'd known Jack
for a while and that's we first worked
together and then that's where we were
like let's do this in there so you look
forward to working with these guys again
in the future then Tom and Jack yeah I
like working people who I know because
any trust each other and you know work
the people are good
and have a nice bond and you can and
that's the kind of half times fun we had
to the experience of making cold
compared to previous functional
obviously made quite few in have any of
the inside course to play I think the
cold is anyone actually a weirdo I put
in a bit more money into it and we end
up with a bit of a budge at the end but
also was the one that was most story
what a most time even though I was still
very quick the previous ones offenders
were very my off-the-cuff and this one
had a bit more time but into and from
the script and a kind of a story woman
point of view but is still very very I
know obviously you've got the night
shift coming out seeing up to the states
to film that but writing and directing
wise what would you like to do next
what's in the back burner for you but
you'd like to bring forward I don't know
I've got a couple of projects it just
depends on which one is easiest to make
mix I don't know I really depend this is
a few people I'm talking to I want to
work with so we're just kind of trying
to figure it out I've got one or two
just don't not sure which one is gonna
drop first there's some sci-fi and some
thrillers and loads of other stuff you
gotta go okay I'm everything everything
apart for a man to come back to it ain't
gonna happen
you